[Music]
what was that moment for both of you
guys when you realize that you needed a
shift that you needed to get sober well
I think drew would agree like I had
known for a while but you just don't
really want to make the change yet you
don't really want to do the work yet you
there's a part of you that knows that
you need to make a change but you just
keep you just can't really shut that
door you can't really shut that door on
your life and just move on to a new
chapter for me it took like something
drastic happening like becoming a father
for me to make the change
Jed Hanks getting candid about a
sobriety woody tea and in his new music
with his band ft RZ the first single is
called models to you about the lyrics in
that what the song signifies for you the
opening lyric of the song is from the
bottom of the bottle to touch in
California models and it goes on to just
talk about how we changed our lives from
basically you know a path of just like
heavy like substance abuse drugs alcohol
partying sold that kind of whole
lifestyle to being better men becoming
better men then then that and being what
we're capable of you know so that's
basically yeah I saw that you actually
posted on your Instagram that your
daughter
saved your life yeah how well if she was
never born mm-hmm I probably I can't say
that I would have had the motivation to
make that drastic change in my life
it was it was the prospect of of having
a kid and I knew that in nine months I'm
gonna there's gonna be a baby here that
gave me the the motivation to be like
okay I have to just I've had my time now
with all that and I need to move on it
just gets the point where you're like
okay like I'm tired enough of this
this this way isn't working and I need
to make a drastic change completely flip
the script to get what I really want out
of life not just settling for this like
mediocre existence but get all the
things in my
I really want 27 year olds also credits
parents Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson for
being a strong support system how they
supported you through your sobriety just
dumped by doing just that just just by
being supportive yeah you know and they
couldn't be more supportive
dude I mean it every step of the way you
know I mean they've always been do they
love seeing you as a dad and this new
side of you I mean you're gonna be three
years sober next month yeah they really
do and they love being grandparents too
it's awesome seeing them being been
grandparents as well because I was
really close with my grandparents and
now my daughter gets to have the same
experience what are they like as
grandparents what do they what do they
do with your little one oh you know just
just just regular stuff just you know
stuff around the house hanging out
spending time taking care taking care of
her you know does she have a Toy Story
woody doll that needs to happen thank
somebody that does need to happen right
over here yes do they ever offer to
babysit yeah all the time yeah but I'm a
better man than that that's what my
balls and dip right I love that you guys
are so willing to be candid and open
lyrically and I feel like a lot of
artists are Eminem Demi Lovato do you
feel like you're helping people with
your message and in opening that
conversation and kind of take your
stigma away definitely hope so 100 I
definitely do I feel a responsibility
you like to tell the truth I'm saying it
and and I M be as open as possible with
it because there's such a bad drug
epidemic like in throughout the world
and especially in America with people
are dropping like flies like especially
from the opiates but but with all across
the board it's really it's a bad problem
and I feel like there should be like no
stigma around people who let get sober
because it you need to be open to be
able to help other people if you just if
you just get sober and then and like try
to keep it a secret you're not really
like helping anybody because there could
be somebody out there that's struggling
really hard and if you can be an
inspiration that person to make the
for them to change their life you can't
put a price on that
you know because because we understand
how hard it is to make like the decision
and stick to it just like I said if I if
my daughter hadn't been born there's
there's no telling that I would have
done it I could easily be better in jail
right now if I hadn't made that decision
so if us just sharing our story can be
the spark for somebody else to make that
decision in their life and and and what
leave the past behind and open up a new
chapter in their life that's that that
is like the most rewarding and the most
fulfilling thing about it it's it's the
best part about about doing the music in
the first place